[Music]
from illumination the creators of
minions
racing trailer Starts Now
[Applause]
[Music]
isn't it beautiful this is awesome maybe
we should go say hi hey there Jack
talked to a girl a girl he wants to
marry her what
say that you said it with your eyes
[Music]
they must be migrating migration what a
stupid idea okay you're impossible
because I found a safe place for us to
live
I wanted
to see the world
[Music]
see if I put my young foul In Harm's Way
for no reason except the chance of the
Caribbean vacation I don't want to miss
out on life because you're afraid to
leave this pond
here we go
Wing deployment
let's fly
why are we the only Birds heading this
way
[Applause]
I promise adventure and this is exactly
what I promised
it is
on top
can we land you're old enough to do it
in the sky now we have a number two
situation oh but it's gross every bird
does it in the sky
no one is looking down there I told you
we are not Landing there is no way we're
Landing
when Mallard do it now or we leave
without you okay okay
we are completely lost we're trying to
get to Jamaica come on love birds it's
this way well we are not flying through
this crazy death trap of a city just
stay close to me and everything will be
all right
but
maybe you don't stick too close